singing back to someone like a stephen j
cannell who was known for what's a
detective shows and things like that
back in rockford rotten right eizan at
ninety singing sure um do you see anyone
similar nowadays that's duplicated that
same type of success he was just such a
name and he still is I think he writes
books now as well but that same type of
branding that one person in television
these days well he was a very important
figure in the history of television and
he worked at a time when a independent
producer like him could create
essentially an empire within the
television world now in the early 90s
the restriction against the networks
from owning their own shows where it was
removed and that ended the days of the
great independent producer now yes we
still have a few of these people around
you know the law and order that that's
that sort of thing of the CSI franchise
and so on but because now networks can
own their own shows they don't have to
go to an independent producer who had
all this power because he knew the
network couldn't on the show so their
position has radically reduced and I
think there's been some advantages to
that but some real disadvantages to it
what elements did you see in his stories
he was a great popular storyteller one
of the best in the history of television
and he had a simple rule that he would
always follow which is that you you you
send the hero up tree you throw rocks at
him and then you try to get him down
that was his structure and and it's a
remarkably simple but very effective
structure for telling a story especially
within the television world and
especially in again the standalone
story because this is that kind of
simplicity of storytelling works
perfectly in the crime and detective
form and that was course what he was the
master of especially in shows like rock
Rockford which were comedy detective
stories this combination very popular
with audiences especially with older
audiences and really CBS built its
entire network based on this type of
show so the the form of the comedy
detective or simply the detective story
which works very well over 44 minutes
because you can quickly set up the
problem typically some kind of a crime
you go through a number of possible
suspects and because he was very good at
trickery at hiding who the real you know
killer is um you then get these nice
reveals at the end of the story boom
it's over the hero has accomplished his
job and I'm happy and that was the power
of the standalone show so he was his
type of storytelling was perfect for the
standalone form now where we have this
much more of an emphasis on the serial
form many more characters many more
storylines there we are interweaving the
this very simple kind of structure where
we send the character up a tree throw
rocks bring them down it is not nearly
sufficient we need a much more advanced
understanding of how to tell a story
that will extend over an entire season
and this by the way is what now the
networks and the cable companies are
looking for which is they want to see
that somebody has the ability to
interweave a vast number of stories keep
them all going and the number of balls
in the air as they say and to be able to
extend
over an entire season this is extremely
difficult to do and that that's why in
my opinion the very best writer is
working in the American entertainment
industry are working on serial TV shows
you